صور مورينيو الغاضب تغزو مواقع التواصل
بونوا يكتبان التاريخ مع اشبيليه
وقالتيه يعلن رحيل ميسي في الصيف
هذه الاخبار وغيرها نقدمها لكم من العربيه
رياضه اهلا بكم
بعد خساره روما لنهائي اليوروبا اشتتحت
صوره ومقاطع فيديو لمدربه الفريق مورينيو
الذي كان غاضبا بشده صفحاتي ومواقع
السوشيال ميديا وحقق فيديو لمورينيو وهو
يوجه كلاما لحكم المباراه نحو خمسه ملايين
مشاهده وهذا على تويتر فقط بينما انتشر
الصوره له وهو يمنح ميداليته للطفل صغير
من مشجع روما انتشرت بقوه عبر مختلفه
منصاته ومواقع التواصل
استمرت ثنائي المغربيه سيمبونو ويوسفنصيري
في كتابه التاريخ خلال الموسم الحالي وبعد
التالق مع منتخب المغرب في كاس العالم قدم
اللاعبان دورا مهما في تتويج فريقهما بلقب
السابع له في تاريخه ضمن مسابقه الدوري
الاوروبي وكان بونو قد تالق بشده في ركلات
الجزاء بعد ابعاد لركلتين ترجيحيتين ليعد
الى الاذهان ظلقوا في المونديال امام
منتخب اسبانيا وتحديدا في الركلات
الترجيحيه
اعلن مدرب باريس سان جيرمان كريستوف غالتي
رحيل نجم الفريق وافضل لاعب في العالم
الارجنتينيه من ميسي النادي باريس سان
جيرمان وقالتيه في مؤتمر صحفي قبل مواجهه
كليرمو بان المباراه المقبله ستكون
الاخيره لميسي على ملعب حديقه الامراء
ارتبط اسمه الانديه من بينهم ناديه السابق
برشلونه في متشير بعض التقارير الى وجود
مفاوضات بينه وبين احد الانديه السعوديه
في خبرين الاخير فجاه لعبه السابق وقائد
برشلونه
بمقطع فيديو اثناء حفل وداع اللاعب في
كامب نو ويعتبر غوارديولا هو من اكتشف
سيرجيو بعدما صعدوا للفريق الاول عام 2008
قبل ان يحصد البارصا كل البطولات الممكنه
في ذلك الموسم وهنئ على مسيرته الكرويه
كما حثوا على السير والاتجاه نحو الحياه
التدريبيه